[Music]
with today's movement towards API
economy supplying your company's
products and services as API s is
crucial to getting your business in the
game the API economy is key to
increasing value improving business
performance and offering your business
services and goods to the widest
possible audience while API bring lots
of opportunities they also present new
and unexpected challenges every day in
the rush to get to market the
requirements for control security
integration and optimization can be
forgotten publishing a new API and
managing its lifecycle effectively and
efficiently is critical by enforcing
proper security policies integrating
with new services and optimizing
performance you can enable secure access
smooth uptake and effective monetization
of your offerings introducing IBM data
power gateways the market leader in
security integration control and
optimization data powers convergent
built to purpose and multi-channel
architecture provides best-in-class
implementations of the most popular
security protocols and industry
standards data power acts as your API
gateway and helps accelerate your
digital transformation by securely
extending your reach across multiple
channels mobile cloud and the Internet
of Things data power provides customers
a robust and flexible solution to expose
their data securely data power is so
well suited to the role of API and
ablenet that iBM has chosen it as the
runtime gateway for API connect in that
role data power acts as the hub through
which API calls pass-through and applies
configured policies to all traffic
policies for authentication and
authorization traffic management routing
and many other capabilities it's
provided four years data powers
implementation of WAP authorization
provides you with full support for the
most common and popular mobile
application security protocol with
first-class TLS acceleration support for
server name indication elliptic curve
cryptography and
pick forward security data power is the
clear market leader for managing and
securing your AP is with new support for
JSON tokens encryption and signing data
power ensures the protection of your API
enabled assets data power support for
API is just part of its well-rounded
support for multiple protocols and
application architectures with the cloud
becoming an important pillar of many
businesses forward-looking IT
initiatives data power is they're
providing hybrid cloud security as well
as all of your other needs data powers
multi-channel support of api's cloud
mobile web SOA and b2b workloads
provides a single control point for all
your business's demands secure your
digital channels with data power gateway
visit ibm.com slash data power and see
what IBM data power gateways can do for
you